have some of the people that have
watched the film been surprised at how
quickly the hollywood machine can pick
someone up and drop them yeah that tends
to be the reaction look from a lot of
people especially especially actors and
filmmakers and but actually even
audience members like people on the
outside that are fascinated with
Hollywood are always very surprised on
like just the fact that like how could
they do that to people or how look how
much this person accomplished and I
don't believe that they lost it so fast
they always think that I guess they're
intrigued by that concept I don't know
but it just what happens in that
business you know so I think did they
tend to kind of say after they seat
there are the people that are not in the
business that like oh I I didn't know
that that's how it works that's what
they did that's the reality you know
especially in that business
if you were coaching someone let's
suppose a person out of college that was
coming to LA yeah and they said I want
to be a filmmaker and actor and they
asked your advice specifically and they
asked you to be very blunt what would
you tell them hmm I'd say watch the
movie I don't know because everybody has
it's like no matter what you tell people
whatever is in your head is in your head
you'll do it and so I always say just
like watch them over there is something
you may see something in there that will
make you go I don't want to go oh you
may see something in there that will
remind you why you're here of certain
things to prevent and it's almost like a
recall process or it's like it'll come
in handy at one point because some
people also see and they go that just
will never happen to me you know we used
to say stuff like that so watch the
movie I don't know I really it's almost
like everybody has their own journey you
have to determine really why do you want
it and why do you want to go to
Hollywood or you want to go to New York
or whenever a Toronto that's it's really
more of an individual kind of
quest in a sense of what to do it
yourself but you know as hard as it is
as a business there's there are also
opportunities so it's really how we
approach it you know do your homework i
guess i would say sure so they can form
their own opinion yeah so are you happy
that this was part of your journey
looking back yeah absolutely um where it
is now because there was a time when I
felt like okay I will never be able to
get out of this like to get out of the
problem but so to be able to get out of
it and actually be able to tell a story
it's like it's it's it has its own
uplifting elements and I I do like that
actually
you